[Music]
hello everyone this session is to
explain how Dragon Quest to walk again
currently very popular in Japan handles
millions of players and how cross mana
is essential to managing high volumes
over the quest
my name is UT customer engineer from
Google cloud working with gaming
industry companies in Japan today I will
tackle who is an engineer from Cobra the
most difficult part of launching a new
game is unpredictability once again gets
popular the Sabha often receives massive
requests in the shortened compute is
very easy to scale if you need more
resources you simply add more Sabbath
but the database often becomes a
bottleneck because legacy databases like
Amish eco are not designed to scale
horizontally so when the database is
overloaded this is what happens for game
players I think this is the most
frustrating error message if you are a
lawyer player maybe it's not a big deal
but if you are logging in for the first
time it may be your last time very few
games can overcome this type of error at
launch so how do you gain companies have
the database scaling problem well in
general gaming company need our DNS and
they use a technique called shadi
which speeds a single database on
different servers for example shutting
can be done by players by geo locations
or by gaming patterns this is a broad
generalization shadding might be a
solution but can lead to hidden cost as
you can see in this iceberg first
maintenance codes for example if a
single database ibaka hundred ten
thousand players suddenly
you need 100 Sabbath for every million
prayers I think no one want to manage
hundreds of servers second up to
creativity players from all over the
world will pray at all times of the day
therefore the database has to function
24/7 it is impossible to find an off
peak maintenance window that
accommodates everyone about downtime
traditional relational databases offer
high availability using a failover
mechanism this means if the data server
fails it will recover but it generates
downtime today Google cloud offers many
types of database including fire store
crawl sicko and subtle party partner
solutions which are designed for various
customer needs Dragon Quest walk has
chosen crud spanner at the database
since it is the ideal fully managed
scalable database crawl spanner combines
the benefits of relational database
structure with non-relational horizontal
scale which means spanner is an our DBMS
Stalin also provides horizontal scaring
scare out it is wholly managed and has
no plant downtime in addition spanner
can provide up to five 9s array and I
mentioned earlier traditional database
have big hidden costs by deploying your
game on clouds panel you can
dramatically reduce to these hidden
costs
smaller can scare out with one-click and
upgrades automatically without downtime
data is replicated across stones which
result in high availability but how does
this translate into numbers when
enterprise strategy group which is a
Research Forum this was three-year TCO
analysis for
spanha against other traditional and
crowd databases they found that you can
save 37% of the cost compared to other
cloud solution and 78% of cost compared
to other on-premise solution the savings
mainly come from hard investment as well
as many administrative tasks that you
need to spend on to make sure your
database stays up and running now let's
hear from our customer corpora and how
they adopted cross spanner in their game
dragon quest walk hi my name is taka and
I'm a software developer for a Japanese
game company called corpora I will take
over from here and briefly talk about
how we use cloud spanner and Dragon
Quest walk before I go into the details
allow me to do a brief introduction
about the game the game is called Dragon
Quest walk and it was developed by us
and published by Square Enix the game is
part of a long-running Dragon Quest
series owned by Square Enix so here are
some screenshots of what the actual game
looks like the game is a merge between
location-based AR and a traditional
turn-based JRPG the game is for mobile
and it's available in Japan for Android
and iOS so here are some numbers to give
you an insight of how much data we
process every day with cloud spanner so
we release this game back in September
of last year and I can't say the exact
exact numbers but we had a lot of users
register on the first day what I can
tell you is that we had over 5 million
downloads on the first week currently we
still have millions of monthly active
users and we process thousands of
Curry's per second across hundreds of
spanner nodes every day here's the
agenda for what I'm going to be talking
about today first I'll start by talking
about why we chose spanner then I will
talk about how we integrated spanner
into our development after that I will
talk about some
the challenges we face with spanner so
here are some of the reasons why we
chose spanner for this game started with
the first one on the list
scaling in and out so we used to use a
self-managed my sequel to handle our
user data and we scaled it by splitting
data into horizontal shards in our past
titles this worked well for us at first
but when the numbers of shards start to
grow into double digits
we started to notice some problems with
this approach the problem arose whenever
we wanted to scale when we scaled these
databases in or out we had to scale
manually and we had to scale once every
few months we would scale out to handle
the high traffic whenever we released a
new feature or whenever we did a C's no
event and then we would scale in to save
costs once the hype cool down in the
traffic East preparing and executing
these tasks took hours and sometimes
days depending on the scale and it was
stressful and time-consuming
by switching to spanner we were able to
do this with one click and scaling would
complete within a few minutes so that
was reason number one so the second
reason we why we chose spanner was for
its stability and her previous titles as
I've mentioned earlier we used a
self-managed my sequel and we used to
get unexpected crashes at least once a
month mostly due to host errors with
spanner everything is managed and all
the problems are handled in the
background now we've been running this
game for over six months now and we
haven't had any major down times just
minor ones and it wasn't spanners fault
so I could confidently say stability has
been good so that was reason number two
the third reason we chose spanner was so
we can write a more readable and
maintainable code previously when we had
to write code for started databases our
code had to be infrastructure aware
which made it hard to read and maintain
one example of this would be something
like distributed transactions where you
have to make transactions across
different shards
this was hard to understand and he was
even harder to be debug especially for
the parts where we had to rollback then
there are things like replication delays
where data retrieved from the replicas
might not be up-to-date so we had to be
careful about where we read our data
from after switching to spanner we were
able to make inserts updates and deletes
in a single transaction and replication
delay became a non-issue because
consistency is guaranteed
now I would like to talk about how we
integrated spanner into our development
when we first decided to use spanner we
had the feeling it was going to be a
bumpy ride since no one at the company
had any experience with it and there was
very little information available online
at the time so we did some preparations
to make sure that the transition from my
sequel to spanner would be smooth and
painless as possible so how do we do
this well first we created a small
dedicated team and by team I mean me and
my colleague so me and my colleague
performs some basic benchmarks to check
the performance and once we confirm that
the performance was good we put in some
extra effort to making a dedicated
driver for a PHP framework we were using
called laravel doing so allowed us to
use pre-existing ORM which in turn
allowed us to reuse existing libraries
we were using for existing games by the
way we've uploaded the driver we wrote
on github so please take a look at it if
you're interested
so once the driver was written we tested
the driver by taking an existing game
and replacing the my sequel driver that
was used with the spanner driver this
worked well because we get to see how it
performs on real scenarios and allowed
us to weed out bugs we couldn't catch
with our automated tests doing this also
helped us get familiar with the database
much quicker than trying to apply it to
a game from scratch after all about that
was done we integrated spanner into the
main game development cycle by doing
these preparations we were able to fully
integrate spanner
into a game in about two weeks now I'll
talk about some of the challenges we
faced with spanner and also talk about
how we overcame those challenges first
one on the list is interleaving spanner
has this concept called interleague
which is crucial for getting optimal
performance out of your queries
interleaving is a concept of having
parent-child relationships between
tables so that data for child tables are
inserted in the same node as the parent
table this is essential because if you
have a has many relation and you try to
get the related rows from the children
it's much more efficient to look it up
within the same node rather than looking
at a across different nodes so enough in
order to account for this new concept we
scan through all the existing schemas we
wrote from my sequel and added
definitions for interleaving for tables
that had a parent-child relationship at
the same time we made sure all the
indexes that mimicked the relationship
in my sequel were removed since they
were unnecessary when the tables are
interleaved another thing we made sure
was that all queries that scan the
interleaved children included the parent
IDs when doing a lookup this was because
omitting it caused spanner to scan the
entire database which degraded
performance tremendously to be
absolutely sure that the parent ID was
included in all the queries we added
some code that listened to all the query
events and threw a warning when the
parent ID was emitted next item on the
list is scaling hiccups so in this game
we scale in and out fairly often based
on how much traffic we're expecting for
the day scaling out is simple since all
you have to do is increase the number of
nodes in the UI and wait a few minutes
for it to be deployed scaling in however
was a bit trickier the asset add the
actual task is the same as scaling out
but we noticed that when we reduce the
number of nodes to aggressively there
was
noticeable response delay these delays
range from a few milliseconds up to
maybe something like 30 seconds
sometimes this is this also caused some
the servers to choke due to too many
connections being open
so we resolve this by forcing spanner to
timeout and three second in three
seconds and return a response to the
client which ask the client to retry the
request after a few seconds in addition
to that we now try to decrease the nodes
in small increments since the range of
delay seems to be proportional to the
number of nodes we do we decrease from
what we can observe if we go easy and
reduce one node for five minutes or so
we managed to minimize the delay enough
that no retries occurred on the client
the next item is handling bursts of
access to shared data so the game has
some small sets of data which is shared
across all users these are things like
item properties and Monster map
Coordinates
we wanted to replicate these data so
access to these data could be
distributed the way to do it in spanner
was to add a column with a shard number
and insert copies of the data with
different shard numbers then what you
can do is have the code so like one of
the shards that random and add that to
the query and that will distribute the
load we thought about doing it this way
but we figured it was too difficult to
implement into the framework at the time
so for shared data we decided to use a
self-managed my sequel instead since it
can replicate and scale out easily if
all you have is a small set of data the
last item on the list is handling launch
day traffic in order to talk about this
I first have to explain what a split is
internally spanner divides our data into
chunks called splits where a split can
move around between servers and when
there is high load on a split it tries
to slice it up and add split boundaries
to distribute the load
this works well and normal scenarios
where there is a gradual increase in
users with gradual growth on load but
this was not what we expected to happen
on launch day what we expected to happen
on launch day was thousands of users
registering in a span of a few seconds
and we knew splitting wasn't going to be
fast enough based on numerous launch day
simulations we've probably performed so
in order to make this work we pre split
the database before the launch we call
this process warming up the database the
way we warmed it up was rather simple we
just forced the splits to trigger by
slowly adding thousands of dummy users
until it's split enough to handle the
launch day traffic after the split was
complete we deleted the dummy users
since the split is retained even after
the users are deleted so the method was
simple but there was one small caveat
these splits were only sustained if
there was access to them otherwise these
splits start to merge again after around
24 hours so we made sure to do the warm
up 24 hours before the actual launch the
warm up was a tedious and time-consuming
task but we're glad we did it because
the launch was a great success with zero
problems before I end I just wanted to
show you how our storage architecture
looks like and briefly explain how
various services are used in conjunction
with spanner all the storage we use is
lined up on the right going from the top
we have spanner which holds all the user
data as you know our analytical data
like user action logs is streamed to
bigquery since bit query works better
for scanning large sums of data our
master data like monsters items and
location data is running on multiple
replicated my sequel servers where the
load is distributed using gke service
then we have memory store which is used
for temporary caching of
currently access data to ease the load
on other storages and I completely
forgot to add to this but we also use
elasticsearch to store parts of our user
data so it can be used to look up names
and other various attributes that's all
from me today thank you
Thank You Tucker feel free to reach out
to us to find out how crowds panic and
address challenges that you may be
facing with the URL to lhamo thank you
for joining today's session
[Music]